am sonntagabend waren prügel und
streicheleinheiten sehr ungleich
verteilt wie immer wenn wahlergebnisse
bekannt werden die den bisherigen
favoriten für die bundestagswahl die
union in selbstzweifel stützen und beim
politischen gegner glückshormone
ausschütten
doch vorsicht coronaviren könnten auch
diesen jüngsten stimmungsumschwung
zunichte machen wahlkampf in pandemie
zeiten werden die karten neu gemischt
jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst dem studio ist lee die blaue
zone politische influence sie gehören im
landtagswahlkampf in mecklenburg
vorpommern in diesem jahr zum social
media wahlkampfteam von manuela schwesig
am gleichen tag wird auch der bundestag
gewählt und sie traten auch die
bundestagswahl kamper der bundes-spd
hier in berlin
ralf fücks 1989 90 co vorsitzender der
damaligen grünen vorstand der
heinrich-böll-stiftung und jetzt
direktor des zentrums liberale moderne
in berlin berlin
diese liberale moderne versteht sich als
think tank und diskussionsplattform zur
erneuerung der liberalen demokratie
zugeschaltet professor karl rudolf korte
politikwissenschaftler der universität
duisburg essen und einer der autoren des
buches das gerade erscheint corona grati
demokratisches regieren in ausnahme
zeiten und schließlich professor andreas
ritter professor für neueste geschichte
an der universität in mainz und
gleichzeitig im moment gastprofessor an
der johns hopkins university in
washington und von seiten von corona und
digitalisierung ist es möglich diese
gastprofessur auch von mainz auszuüben
und sie sind auch mitglied der cdu karl
rudolf korte
seit gestern abend geht auf twitter der
hashtag wir wollen karl viral damit ist
gemeint dass jens spahn der
bundesgesundheitsminister durch karl
lauterbach als gesundheitsminister
ersetzt werden soll
das ist ja eigentlich ein sehr schönes
beispiel wie sich pandemie und politik
verbinden lassen
ja in der distanz demokratie ist ganz
vieles außer alltäglich und fiel nach
aus der wahlforschung vergleichsmaßstäbe
insofern waren wir ganz neugierig was am
sonntag passiert ist aber die stimmungen
sind eben auch unter bahn.de die
bedingungen nicht wirklich planbar
was vorliegt ist eben die mobilisierung
für
die bundestagswahl und das spielen in
der tat personen eine rolle und
vielleicht ist das ja auch noch teil der
sendung überlegungen ob man über
kabinettsumbildungen durchaus in einer
offensive kommen kann um dann natürlich
mit thema und neun personen auch
aufmerksamkeit auf sich zu ziehen
sprechen wir gerne an vielleicht noch
mal auf diesen hashtag wir wollen karl
kommen sie haben ja 35 tausend follower
auf twitter sind denn da so viele von
ihrem parteifreund karl lauterbach
begeistert denn der fordert ja tag und
nacht rigorose einen rigorosen lockdown
wir sehen auf jeden fall einen versagen
von ihren sparern vielen stellen die
menschen sind unzufrieden mit der ganzen
corona politik bzw mitteilen der korona
politik natürlich und da würde sie sich
einfach einen klaren kurs und der ist
aktuell nicht ersichtlich den sehe ich
auch nicht und deshalb kann ich gut
nachvollziehen dass es da auch wünsche
gibt den bundesgesundheitsminister zu
entlassen und eben jemanden mit einem
sehr klaren kurs egal wie man zu ihm
steht daneben zu einzusetzen
in höchstform literatur nobelpreisträger
albert kamin ist der satz überliefert
die höchste hoffnung ist die überwundene
verzweiflung also wovon darf die
politische linke in deutschland jetzt
träumen
ich wollte hier ziemlich zur politischen
linken sagen zählen linksliberal also
leicht linksliberal würde vielleicht
koalition ohne die union anstreben
da fühlen sich vielleicht eher natürlich
ist das jetzt sagen denn der neue hype
und tatsächlich sieht es so aus als ob
es eine politische alternative zu
schwarz grün geben könnte nach der
bundestagswahl wovon in den letzten
monaten ja eigentlich alle ausgegangen
sind dass es das sagen wird aber die
hürden für eine ampel als alternative
sind noch sehr hoch
nicht nur programmatisch
sagen die nötigen übereinstimmung
zwischen diesen drei wochen sehr
verschiedenen politischen kräften
herzustellen
auch die politische dynamik in den
nächsten monaten ist kaum kalkulierbar
und es fehlen ja immer noch nominell 34
5 prozent
um diese alternative auch mehrheitsfähig
zu machen
höre da ein bibel fester christlicher
politiker wenn der die worte hosianna
und kreuzigt ihn hört weiß sofort
bescheid um was es geht wir gehen davon
aus dass das auch bei jens spahn der
fall ist der ist noch vor kurzer zeit
als kanzlerkandidat gehandelt worden
jetzt als buhmann steht als buhmann da
bei dem mann jetzt alles ablehnt
fokussiert sich in der person von die
entspannen
all das was der cdu gerade zu schaffen
macht in der person von jetzt sparen
fokussieren sich im moment zwei dinge
schon zum einen das was sie gerade sagen
die probleme die den
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der regierung in
der gesamten bevölkerung und damit
übrigens auch eine gefährdung für die
glaubwürdigkeit des gesamten politischen
systems begleiten das ist das eine
aber auf der anderen seite natürlich
auch diese immer stärker werdenden
aufgeregtheiten des politischen
geschäfts wie sie gerade über jens
sparen sagen rosi anna und kreuzige team
das erinnert mich natürlich auch an
martin schulz vor vier jahren
und diese ganzen aufgeregtheiten
insbesondere durch die sozialen medien
dieser achterbahnfahrt der popularität
die überhaupt nicht abzuschätzen ist das
macht natürlich rationale vernünftige
und überzeugende politik zu gestalten
nicht leichter er konnte die das jetzt
die asta dass jetzt da ich habe einen
rückten auf dem ohr weil ich nur sagen
er konnte das jetzt asta zenica
ausgesetzt wird gibt das der pandemie
strategie der bundesregierung den rest
eigentlich pipi entspannen ja gar nichts
anderes übrig als diese empfehlung des
paul-ehrlich-instituts zu folgen
naja erstmal sind wahlen ein
verlässlicher gradmesser für das
vertrauen und trotz der aufgeregtheiten
trotz der schluss kritik in den letzten
tagen an der union wegen der masken
affäre ist es so dass die wählerinnen
und wähler am sonntag ja die politische
mitte verbreitert haben die extreme sind
geringer geworden und unter dem
vorzeichen würde ich auch ihre frage
diskutieren
im prinzip kann man noch davon ausgehen
dass wir bei der bundestagswahl eine
geimpfte republik haben was wir auch
noch zeitgleich haben ist so ein
infizierter blick dass wir also anderen
menschen die wir sehen nicht trauen weil
sie vielleicht uns anstecken können also
eher einen bogen rummachen also dieses
asoziale reagieren auf andere menschen
das werden wir nicht so schnell wieder
ablegen aber in einer geimpften republik
hat natürlich die partei die cdu die
union insgesamt auch die regierung
durchaus pluspunkte und darauf setzt sie
ja im moment natürlich kann es passieren
dass bis dahin andere impfstoffe auch
versagen nicht kommen so weiter dann
wird es eine notregierung am ende geben
aus all parteien wie man sich das in
solchen spektakulären krisen seiten
vorstellt
im moment geht glaube ich auch die
bundesregierung davon aus dass impfstoff
ankommen wird weiter dass er geimpft
werden kann dass wir vielleicht bis zur
bundestagswahl alle einmal in urlaub
fahren und insofern die farbe im umfeld
von mobilisierung für die bundestagswahl
eine andere sein wird als im augenblick
ich würde das nicht überbewerten das im
moment alles offenbar nach chaos und
nicht klappen sorgenvoll echt aussieht
sondern dass hier auch noch andere
phasen erwarten sind
man könnte ja sagen dass dieser
impfstoff auch jetzt zur beruhigung
beitragen könnte was professor claudia
gerade gesagt hat mit ihm zudem republik
ist auch eine beruhigte republik dazu
müsste dieser astrazeneca impfstoff
wieder zugelassen werden das wusste auch
manches gut laufen wie sehen sie die
entwicklung wenn es nicht so läuft wie
wir uns das alle eigentlich wünschen
ich glaube wir sollten nicht
unterschätzen
welcher wut pegel sich da gerade sagen
aufbaut
ich merke das auch manchmal bei mir
selber und in meiner nächsten umgebung
eigentlich alles rationale und
vernünftige sagen leute die aber doch
zunehmend verzweifelt sind über diese
reduzierung von sozialen kontakten und
das eindampfen unseres ganzen geselligen
lebens haben das nicht reisen können die
einschränkungen von persönlichen
begegnungen und ich glaube dass im
letzten jahr gab es noch eine stimmung
die die von hoffnung geprägt werde in 20
21 lassen wir das alles hinter uns und
wenn jetzt die dritte welle tatsächlich
voll durchschlägt und wir wieder in
einen harten sagen lockdown gehen dann
wird die die stimmung in der bevölkerung
glaube ich ziemlich wütend sie findet
nur keinen politischen ausdruck ja wen
soll man in solchen situationen
politisch verantwortlich machen zumal
alle verantwortlichen sich
hintereinander sagen verstecken ja das
ist ja ein phänomen dieser krise finde
ich diese verantwortung die fusion ja
wofür ist ja nicht die eu verantwortlich
wo für die bundesregierung wofür die
länder das ist alles ein grosser seinem
mischmasch und deshalb ist es auch so
schwer jetzt klare zuordnung zu machen
für fehlentscheidungen verantwortung ist
ein wichtiges stichwort wer hat
eigentlich die verantwortung ist sind ja
nicht nur die bundeskanzlerin und der
bundesgesundheitsminister der
möglicherweise durch fehleinschätzung
im falle von jens spahn wahrscheinlich
auch durch voreilige ankündigungen da
einiges verbockt haben denn da gibt es
ja noch den koalitionspartner die spd in
der bundesregierung diese beschlüsse
mitgetragen hat es gibt 16 länder
chefinnen und chefs unter anderem auch
manuela schwesig die damit mischt es
gibt die eu kommission müsste man nicht
da etwas differenzierter bei dieser
diskussion vorgehen irgendwie sind ja
alle mit beteiligt denn nicht den oder
die einzige schuldige
ich glaube dass die
gut sich einfach ausdrücken muss auch
ein stück weit ich meine es ist ja nicht
nur das impfchaos ist auch das problem
dass es wahnsinnig viele menschen in
diesem land gerade gibt die vor dem
wirtschaftlichen und finanziellen ruin
stehen also das wird definitiv auch
angebrachte total nachvollziehbar
und da geht es am ende meines erachtens
auch nicht immer wirklich um parteien
sondern einfach einem generellen
misstrauen gegenüber der politik von
daher natürlich ist es im politischen
geschäft einfach oder oder auch
nachvollziehbar da immer anderen leuten
irgendwie die die schuld zuzuschieben
aber letztendlich müssen wir uns einfach
nur überlegen wie es denn die stimmung
in diesem land auch der politik generell
gegenüber
und wie gehen wir damit um sie haben ja
gerade schon mal den das stichwort
kabinettsumbildung ins gespräch gebracht
wenn jetzt da ich sage es mal etwas
salopp so viel in die grütze gefahren
wird ist es aber trotzdem für eine
kabinettsumbildung nicht zu spät wir
haben in ziemlich genau sechs monaten
die bundestagswahl davor noch einen
bundestagswahlkampf ein neues kabinett
mit neuen ministerinnen und ministern
hätte ja kaum zeit zur einarbeitung
macht das überhaupt noch sinn
die demokratie ist ja nicht ohne grund
die optimistische staatsform die wir
kennen weil wir als bürger zuversicht
will und nicht einfach abrechnen im
sinne einer evaluation an der
legislaturperiode die zuversicht
verbindet sich mit themen natürlich mit
programmen und auch mit personen die
relativ schnell bekannt macht die man
relativ schnell bekannt machen kann
in der medien- republik und das wichtige
ist dass man ihnen vertrauen
entgegenbringt und da ist normal ein
besonderer akzent zu sehen mit der
zensur durch frau merkel die eben als
erste kanzlerin auch nicht mehr antritt
haben wir ja nicht nur die konstellation
eine bundestagswahl historisch einmalig
ohne eine titelverteidigerin sondern sie
trägt auch eine kulturelle zäsur das was
wir eben zusammengetragen haben aus wut
vorräten die da sind mit ein bisschen
nach aufgefangen durch frau merkel die
als solidität garant für viele bürger
und bürgerwehr 16 jahre gilt wie bringt
man dieses grundsolide vertrauen
entgegen was eine demokratie braucht das
ist also so fällt auch noch mal eine
erschwernis bei der bundestagswahl aber
dieses vertrauen müsste auf neue
personen übertragen werden
und wenn mit den personen das nicht nur
um irgendwelche namen geht sondern damit
auch eine perspektive verbunden ist die
nicht nur einmal reparaturarbeiten am
wohlfahrtsstaats betrifft sondern eine
führungs erzählung verbindet wohin jetzt
die union wenn sie etwas um bild im
kabinett führen möchte dann macht das
sinn und insofern werden wir neugierig
dann seien auf die person und auf das
programm was damit verbunden wird und
neugierde ist nichts schlechtes
das schlimmste was ein politiker
passieren kann ist eine große demütigung
durch nichtbeachtung rotter wenn jetzt
über diese frage diskutiert wird und man
liest ja auch jetzt auch einen letzten
tagen wieder in einer seit längerer zeit
schon ziemlich aufgeregten medien
republik vieles über den zustand der
bundesregierung ist die stehend ko heißt
stehen caro angela merkel ist karl
rudolf korte hat es ja gerade auch noch
einmal gesagt
am ende einer 16 jährigen amtszeit also
wenn jemand am ende einer 16 jährigen
amtszeit frisch aus dem amt gehen würde
dann würde da er auch irgendwas nicht
stimmen
die ihrer merkel geht zu ende und wir
erleben dass sich das im moment damit
verbindet und das würde ich schon noch
mal deutlich sagen dass der burgfriede
in diesem land der burgfriede über
corona bricht es ist nicht unüblich dass
eben situationen der krise zunächst
immer dann sprechen wir von der stunde
der exekutive so etwas wie ein
allgemeines vertrauen zu den handelnden
institutionen und personen eintritt wie
gesagt dass der burgfriede war das im
ersten weltkrieg als wilhelm der zweite
gesagt hatte ich kenne keine deutsche
keine parteien mehr
ich kenne nur noch deutsche so wird es
vor einem jahre kannten keine parteien
mehr bekannten nur noch virologen aber
jetzt ist dieser burgfriede tatsächlich
gebrochen und die verbindung aus dem
ende des burgfriedens mit dem ende
der ihrer merkel und den damit
verbundenen unabsehbar keiten das macht
das ganze natürlich so problematisch das
macht es so heikel insbesondere für die
union denn wenn kann und auf konnte
davon spricht dass man neugierig auf
eine führungs erzählung sein müsse
dann würde ich dem ganz zustimmen aber
da wäre ich besonders neugierig denn das
ist natürlich für die cdu eine frage die
führungs erzählung die nicht nur
reparaturarbeiten beinhaltet sondern
tatsächlich eine eigene konzeptionelle
strategie der union für die 20er jahre
beinhaltet das ist schon eine ganz
erhebliche aufgaben erfolgs geht da die
aktuelle deutsche innenpolitik gerade
aus dem leim
ich glaube ich schon dass diese krise
doch ein schock erfahrung es sind vieler
hinsicht ja sagen wir merken jetzt
solchen schlagartig wie viel zeit wir
verloren haben in der digitalisierung
der republik
das digitalisierte und pflichten
verwaltungen der gesundheitsämter dass
schulen der werden plötzlich rückstände
seien aufgedeckt die natürlich die
politik zu verantworten hat das ist zu
wenig in die zukunft investiert worden
seien in den letzten jahren die trägheit
der öffentlichen verwaltung wenn es
jetzt so was schon um das impf sagen
management geht ja also dinge auf die
wir eigentlich stolz waren wir dachten
sind eigentlich ein hochleistungs sagen
republik das funktioniert gut diese
diese bundesrepublik deutschland und
jetzt zeigt sie mir sind längst nicht so
gut wie wir oder jedenfalls wie viele
sang geglaubt haben und es wird doch
deutlich dass zu wenig zukunft in der
politik war in den letzten jahren und
zuviel irgendwie durchwurschteln und
verwaltung des status quo und deshalb
glaube ich schon dass wir jetzt in einer
zäsur sind und dass diejenigen politisch
gewinnen werden die ein glaubwürdige und
seriöse erzählung haben wie
der stärker die herausforderungen
bewältigen können für den wir es stehen
globalisierung klimawandel digitale
revolution ja das sind jetzt die großen
themen die in den letzten jahren
schleifen gelassen wurden
als angela merkel zum ersten mal als
bundeskanzlerin vereidigt verband sind
drei jahre alt jetzt gibt es ja immer
wieder diesen vorwurf diese politik sei
viel zu erratischen andererseits auf dem
anderen seite steht aber auch es war
eine enorme wirtschaftliche soziale
stabilität in diesen in einem großteil
dieser 16 jahre zu verzeichnen
brauchen wir jetzt für die zukunft
gerade aus sicht einer jungen frau
brauchen wir für die zukunft einfach
mehr mut und risiko und diese alten
einen geschliffenen bahnen zu verlassen
wir brauchen auf der einen seite und das
ist auch ein ganz großes bedürfnis
junger menschen dass wir einfach
jemanden haben in dem wir vertrauen
können der uns sicherheit gibt ich meine
für meine generation das ist ein völlig
neues bild oder ein völlig neuer gedanke
dass es dass wir irgendwann mal keine
arbeit finden können das war ja früher
nie etwas das irgendwie in unseren in
unseren köpfen möglich war weil wir
einfach in einem see oder in einem sehr
von wohlstand geliebten land leben
dürfen
fakt ist aber auch dass viele
investitionen auch gerade durch frau
merkel verschlafen wurden und dass es da
einfach ein kurswechsel braucht ich sehe
die union ganz ehrlich zur
bundestagswahl hin klaren nachteil
wir haben kanzlerkandidaten wir haben
programm die union hat wirrwarr und
irgendwie eine diskussion nach der
anderen im total blassen
parteivorsitzenden also ich sehe uns da
tatsächlich ganz gut aufgestellt
wirklich auch ab dem 26
die regierung anzuführen da wären wir
noch nach checken ob gleich im laufe der
sendung ob das bei der spd wirklich
besser ist und wer das vergleichen aber
noch eine frage herr karte zu einem
wichtigen werkstoff in der politik
nämlich den teflon
bisher war es ja so gewesen jeder ärger
perlte an angela merkel und der union ab
auch wenn er noch so groß war die
erfolge der politik gingen mit den
beiden mit angela merkel und ihren
beiden unionsparteien nach hause auch
wenn die erfolge eigentlich der spd zu
verdanken waren in der regierungsarbeit
da scheint sich gerade etwas zu ändern
warum ist das so weil sich das mit dem
ende merkel zeitlich deckt das ist dann
auch ein machtverlust der sichtbar wird
und das wäre glaube ich die einfachste
erklärung zu dieser wahrnehmung dass das
situative das tentative offenbar nicht
mehr ausreicht und wir spüren dass das
auf sicht fahren was gerne wieder
gewählt wurde und was frau merkel
neulich in einer pressekonferenz auch
noch mal so schön zusammengefasst hat
dass sie ja morgens wenn sie ins büro
komme nicht weiß was sie mittags zu
entscheiden hat ist nämlich auch genauso
endet gerade unter den rahmenbedingungen
dieser krise merken wir dass diese
situations kanzlerschaft auch als
kanzler präsidentin hilfreich war in
bestimmten konstellationen aber am
endpunkt zu läuft nicht nur
machtpolitisch weil wir uns an diesen
wirklichkeit gehorsam auch gewöhnt haben
in der beschreibung von wirklichkeit zu
glänzen aber nie ein möglichkeit sinn
ins auge gefasst haben das passt nicht
so merkel ist muss wer keine
möglichkeiten beschreibt sträubt sich
auch gestaltungs ziele zu beschreiben
und wer keine ziele vorgibt möchte auch
nicht über unterschiedliche ziele
streiten
dieses unter argumentieren dass guten
regierens durchaus kommt in eine phase
in der wir jetzt nicht weiterkommen und
erfolgs hat es gesagt noch mal oder
aufgegriffen mit der erzählung es gibt
ein in der krise gewachsene normativen
bedarf nach orientierung
wir können andere themen aufrufen dass
die kirchen den auch nicht leisten auf
jeden fall diese sehnsucht ist da und
die kann man mit zuversicht füllen vor
allen dingen vor dem hintergrund dass
wir ja gemerkt haben in den letzten jahr
das glaubenssätze der politik gar nicht
gelten
daraus kann man sehr viel an
offensivkraft entwickeln binnengrenzen
waren angeblich nie mehr schließt sie
sind geschlossen und präsenz in firmen
war zwingend notwendig damit die firma
läuft das ist ja alles nicht wahr
also was können wir schaffen wenn wir
das übersetzen alles offenbar alles ist
möglich wenn wir uns auf die zukunft
projizieren auf die schwerpunktsetzung
daraus kann man unglaublich viel
entwickeln im sinne einer
zuversichtlichen zukunfts kraft und das
ist der punkt der mann also dem was man
als neue führung anzubieten hätte und
daran merken wir im moment dass eine ära
zu ende geht mit der person von frau
merkel aber auch dieser merkel ist muss
damit endet und damit durchaus die
chancen für die spd wachsen
oder wie kann denn das ist ja praktisch
wie ein bruch wie eine zäsur mit der
ehre angela merkel auch wenn jetzt die
union nach der bundestagswahl wieder den
bundeskanzler stellen sollte wie kann
man diesen bruch aber so überbrücken
dass man sich da nicht von der eigenen
vergangenheit distanzieren muss und
jeder fragt steht die cdu nicht zu den
16 jahren angela merkel die ja so
schlecht nicht gewesen sein können sonst
wäre sie nicht 16 jahre bundeskanzlerin
gewesen
die cdu kann natürlich auch gar nicht
den bruch mit der ära merkel und ihrer
politik vollziehen
aber sie muss und das ist ja kein
widerspruch die zukunft ganz aktiv in
den blick nehmen aber das bedeutet dann
dass sie konzepte für diese zukunft
entwickeln muss die sich aus jetzt von
der cdu ausgesprochen aus
christdemokratischen gedankengut heraus
ableiten und aus diesem gedankengut
heraus argumentiert werden und die auch
eigene und unterscheidbare politische
positionierungen darstellen die cdu muss
die frage beantworten die union
insgesamt muss die frage beantworten
warum soll man die union will und nicht
eine andere partei zb die grünen das
heißt eine reine politik des anpassen
oder wie das im politischen betrieb
gerne heißt man müsse ein thema abräumen
das andere aufgetischt haben das kann
kein zukunftsträchtiges rezept sein dass
die cdu muss aufpassen dass das
aphrodisiakum der macht das sehen durch
eine geschmeidige anpassung an rot-grüne
strömungen zu sich genommen hat sich
nicht dann letztendlich doch als
lähmendes gift erweist und für die cdu
ist die große aufgabe ich sage es noch
einmal
eigenständige und unterscheidbarer
politik entwürfe zudem fragen zu
entwickeln die karl rudolf korte gerade
angedeutet hat wenn jetzt gerade die
merkel jahre sich dadurch ausgezeichnet
dass man versucht hat in der ganzen
breite politik zu machen alle mit
einzubeziehen
zum teil auch politische umarmung dazu
geführt haben dass die spd sich in der
zeit lang überlegt hat ob es überhaupt
einen eigenen kanzlerkandidaten
aufstellen soll gegen angela merkel
jetzt ist diese ära zu ende
dieser breiten politischen aufstellung
kriegen ist denn die parteien gerade die
union aber auch die anderen dann so gut
hin sich wieder stärker zu profilieren
abzugrenzen wieder schärfere
unterschiede zu produzieren und damit
eigentlich auch in der politischen
stimmung im land wieder mehr schärfe in
die auseinandersetzung zu bringen
eine politische alternativen
herauszuarbeiten und klare
unterscheidbare profile das ist schon
notwendig in der demokratie aber
möglichst ohne die gesellschaft zu
spalten das ist ja das kunststück also
sagen eine eigenständige
unverwechselbare politische programmatik
zu entwickeln und trotzdem
integrationsfähig zu sein und die
gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten statt sie
auseinander zu treiben ich halte nichts
von der politik die darauf setzt die 51%
zu erobern und dann durchzuregieren das
funktioniert nicht in einer komplexen
und modern sein gesellschaft wir
brauchen auch lagerübergreifenden
allianzen wenn es zum beispiel um die
klimapolitik sein geht die über eine
legislaturperiode hinweg auch tragen
also man muss sagen beides orientierung
geben wie herr korte sagt und
gleichzeitig aber integrieren ja die die
die gesellschaft nicht in ihre einzelnen
bestandteile zu zerlegen die dann alle
gegeneinander feindlich losmarschieren
auch die demokratie eine runderneuerung
müssen wir das demokratische
zusammenleben
neu denken oder anders denken ich glaube
dass die demokratie auch antworten
darauf geben muss wie sich unsere
gesellschaft entwickelt hat ich meine
wir hatten das ja vorhin schon
angesprochen das ganze thema soziale
netzwerke wie man damit eigentlich
umgeht wie man auch damit umgeht dass es
in den sozialen netzwerken oder es dort
eben der gewinnt der die ökonomie der
aufmerksamkeit irgendwie gewinnt dass
das natürlich auch eine gefahr für die
demokratie sein kann und für
politikerinnen und politiker und
insgesamt die debatte ist glaub ich klar
und dass wir darauf antworten brauchen
und insgesamt diskurs darüber wie wir
miteinander eigentlich umgehen wie wir
auch solche fragen beantworten also
gerade in zeiten einer pandemie ich mein
ich habe das ja vorhin schon
angesprochen wir haben große probleme
es geht hier nicht nur noch darum oder
es geht nicht darum
man kommt jetzt im gesetzentwurf xy
sondern es geht darum dass menschen
gerade einfach vor dem aus stehen und
dass menschen sterben und die gesundheit
gefährdet ist und da brauchen wir klare
antworten und ich glaube da muss auch
die demokratie und der diskurs und
insgesamt auch politische parteien
antworten was ich meine die frage auch
noch über die korona zeiten die
hoffentlich bald vorbei sind hinaus
betrachtet es gibt ja noch andere
probleme globalisierung digitalisierung
das bleibt uns ja nichts erspart da gibt
es eine menge sozialer verwerfungen auch
was muss die demokratie der leisten die
muss sie sich dieser technologischen vor
allen dingen technologisch bedingten
veränderungen anpassen oder besser
gesagt wie sorgt sie dafür dass ich
diese veränderungen der demokratie
anpasst
also ich glaube auf jeden fall dass die
demokratie und politik insgesamt
einladender und inklusiver werden muss
es darf nicht sein dass dieser zb durch
den nassen skandal aktuell dass wir
diese diese wahnsinnig große
unterscheidung oder distanz zur politik
haben das dürfen wir nicht weiter tragen
ich glaube da müssen wir es schaffen
dass auch die menschen sich mehr
mitgenommen fühlen und auch insgesamt
mehr eingebunden werden
also da braucht es auf jeden fall
schritte damit wir die leute jetzt auch
nicht verlieren und das nicht so wirkt
als würde irgendwie mpk bundesregierung
und länder oder insgesamt die politik
machen was sie will und die menschen
werden überhaupt nicht angezogen also
das ist ja die frage was passiert oder
was lernen wir aus der jetzigen zeit
hatte ich hab's menschen angesprochen
dass
buch corona kratie dass sie jetzt mit
verfasst haben untertitel demokratisches
regieren in ausnahme zeiten bezieht sich
zunächst mal jetzt auf diese besondere
situation die ja in jedem fall noch
dieses jahr anhalten wird und in ihren
konsequenzen noch sehr viel länger was
bedeutet dass auch für die zukunft der
demokratie des demokratischen
zusammenlebens das ist bei uns ja im
grundgesetz gefasst da hat man
eigentlich relativ klare vorstellungen
das hat jetzt auch 72 jahre lang relativ
gut geklappt
was ist da was steht da an
unvermeidbaren veränderungen ins haus
na ja man hat ja in dieser stille
gestellten zeit die aufklärerische
wirkung des virus gesehen herr fuchs hat
schon davon gesprochen was gut und was
schlecht läuft ist klarheit vor getreten
was unerwartet war wir haben komplexität
praktisch aufgelöst und dann durch die
auflösung des lok bei uns wieder
zusammengeführt es war ein großes
gesellschaftliches experiment man kann
schon sagen dass es politisch
funktioniert hat dass die demokratie
funktioniert hat war am sonntag hat man
das gesehen eben das nicht dass radikale
extrem am ende gewählt worden ist
sondern das bekannte was sich offenbar
als krisen lotsen auch bewährt hat auch
die föderalen strukturen haben sich
bewährt bei aller kritik an fehlender
falscher kommunikation aber in einer
krise muss man wissen teilen und im
sinne des wettbewerbsföderalismus ist
das auch klug geteilt worden und
unterschiede sind dadurch sichtbar
geworden weil das virus auch
unterschiedlich gewirkt hat und zu
geschlagen also man kann schon sagen
auch die machtteilung hat funktioniert
aber die perspektive die daraus sich
entwickelt für ein demokratisches
zusammenleben kann nur heißen und das
haben wir eben gelernt dass wir mehr auf
resilienz achten auch eben in der
politik das heißt wissen eine chance
geben sie zuzulassen nicht für jede
entscheidung aber doch praktisch den
wissens- raum zu erweitern an dem auch
eben bürger zu beteiligen sind viel
stärker
alles mehr auf lernen zu stellen auf das
bewusste lernen und auch fehler
freundlicher zu agieren so dass wir ein
sensorium entwickeln auch für politische
handlungsfähigkeit für kommende krisen
und der herausforderung denn mit dem
unwahrscheinlichen zu rechnen
das wird der alltag seien auch der
zukunft der politik und da reicht es
nicht nur auf bewährtes zu setzen
sondern gerade dass der blick auf das
bewährte auf die routine führt in der
regel zum desaster ich muss auf das
innovative auf die veränderung setzen um
die neue krise das kann eine ganz andere
sein dann zu meistern so fern kann man
glaube ich ganz gut erkennen dass wir
einerseits gemeistert haben in der
politik in der demokratie die qualität
der demokratie nicht gedimmt haben
sondern sie ist erhalten geblieben und
gleichermaßen konsequenzen ziehen um
meine fitness zu erreichen kommende
krisen zu erhalten besser zu bewältigen
fuchs wie sieht die liberale moderne aus
um den namen ihres instituts
aufzugreifen würde gerne anknüpfen
korte und würde sagen das ja diese mut
zur innovation die bereitschaft zu neuen
das müssen wir stärken aber gleichzeitig
braucht es so etwas wie eine elementare
grundsicherheit vor allem für diejenigen
in der bevölkerung die veränderungen
eher als bedrohung empfinden fast alle
modernen gesellschaften teilen sich so
etwa in diese zwei sagen gruppen
diejenigen die veränderungen umarmen die
sich dabei wohlfühlen dich sagen mit der
digitalisierung schwimmen die fische
sagen im wasser die auch von der
globalisierung profitieren weil sie sehr
gut ausgebildet sind mehrsprachig
internationale netzwerke haben und
diejenigen die er am althergebrachten
festhalten wollen und die veränderung
als gefährdung ihres sozialen status
auch ihrer kulturellen sicherheit sehen
und das müssen wir zusammenbringen
sicherheit im wandel sagen gewährleisten
also die die aufgeschlossenheit für das
das neue den mut zur innovation und
gleichzeitig aber glaubwürdige botschaft
dass niemand zurückgelassen wird ja das
geht um starke öffentliche institution
wie wir jetzt gesehen haben ein starkes
öffentliches sein gesundheitssystem ist
elementar wichtig auch unter dem
stichwort resilienz es geht um bildung
qualifizierung weiterbildung befähigung
mit veränderungen sagen schritt zu
halten also wir brauchen diese balance
zwischen einer handlungsfähigen staat
und einer selbstbewussten aktiven
bürgergesellschaft weiter wenn wir uns
ganz kurz politisches casting mal zu
trauern denn der letzte sonntag hat er
gezeigt wie wichtig auch personen in der
politik sind wenn wir jetzt auf die
bundesebene sehen nach der ära angela
merkel nach der bundestagswahl wie ist
es denn da um das anforderungsprofil
unsere politischen klasse bestellt ich
nenne mal die namen die möglicherweise
mit der regierungsbildung im herbst zu
tun haben also lasche zögern olaf scholz
baerbock und habe und vielleicht obwohl
das nicht so gern hört als
mehrheitsbeschaffer noch christian
lindner
wie sieht es da aus mit den mit diesen
anforderungsprofil an die
zukunftsausgaben ach was soll ich jetzt
sagen soll ich jetzt noten den
politikern geben die sie gerade genannt
alle tourdaten über diese personen ja
ich würde wenn sie erlauben doch gern
noch mal auf das zurückkommen was wir
jetzt gerade besprochen haben denn ich
würde ganz gerne in diese geben was
diagnose doch eine etwas skeptischere
note bringen es kann sein dass das was
karl rudolf korte als befund der
demokratie in der pandemie formuliert
hat dass das am schluss und am ende des
jahres unser befund sein wird aber ich
würde nicht mein gesamtes vermögen
darauf wetten und es ist schon richtig
dass wir möglichkeit räume vor augen
haben müssen
und da stehen ja auch
andere möglichkeiten im raum wenn ich
auf greife das herr fuchs vom
handlungsfähigen staat sprach dann ist
das gefolgt um richtig der staat muss
handlungsfähig sein wo er dringend
benötigt wird und die bürger des landes
erleben den start im moment im
zusammenhang des impfens als nicht in
dem maße handlungsfähig wie er wie man
das von diesem staat erwartet hat und
wenn sie auch auf die europäische ebene
schauen also auch das centre for
european reform das nun wirklich
europafreundlich ist spricht vom im
chaos auf der ebene der europäischen
kommission
also wir erleben hier im moment die
gefahr von glaubwürdigkeitsverluste im
politische institutionen auf
europäischer und auf nationaler ebene
die nicht unerheblich sind da sind
risikopotenziale im moment im gange die
enorm sind und als historiker habe ich
vor augen wie schnell sich dinge ändern
können wie man es gar nicht erwarten
würde
ich habe immer vor vor meinem geistigen
auge die situation der habsburger
monarchie im frühjahr 1918 hätte auch
niemand erwartet dass die am ende des
jahres aufgelöst sein würde sowas kann
schneller gehen als man denkt ich will
jetzt nicht in karl lauterbach der
staatspolitik spielen hier als kassandra
auftreten aber ich würde schon gerne die
die gefährdungen und die
gefährdungspotenziale benennen die wir
hier haben wir wollen ja noch mal daran
setzen an dem was herr fuchs es braucht
einen handlungsfähigen staat und die
aufgabe der politik ist im moment die
handlungsfähigkeit des staates zu
gewährleisten und zu kommunizieren um
dieses vertrauen in die staatlichen
institutionen zu bewahren oder
wiederherzustellen das würde ich im
moment sagen ist eine der wichtigsten
aufgaben für die politik in deutschland
gut jetzt wollen wir nicht hoffen dass
die entwicklung in deutschland zwischen
dem frühjahr und im herbst 1918 er
vergleichbar ist mit der entwicklung in
deutschland von frühjahr bis herbst 2021
und denkt jetzt einen zweiten versuch
mit der kopfnoten frage
konzentriere mich jetzt auf die partei
der sie selbst angehören olaf scholz
wird ja manchmal als ampelmännchen
bezweifelt dass es gar nicht abwertend
gemeint sondern dass er eben auch offen
ist für die bürgerliche mitte er tritt
im auftrag einer dezidiert linken
parteiführung mit einem linken
wahlprogramm an kann das gut gehen
natürlich kann das gutgehen ich meine
wir hatten olaf scholz hat auch rot grün
in hamburg regiert also ich würde ihn
jetzt nicht bescheiden ich nicht mit so
eingenommenen partei konservativer zu
sein wenn sie mich ausgehen ja bitte ich
sage aber nicht ganz so linken partei
genossinnen und genossen wie jetzt an
der führungsspitze der bundespolitik wir
haben ein parteiprogramm entwurf und
olaf scholz hat sich an dem programm
prozess beteiligt und er wird dieses
programm auch als kanzlerkandidat
vertreten und ich bin sehr optimistisch
dass wir mit ihm einen kandidaten haben
der auf der einen seite die sicherheit
bietet die wir vorher auch schon
angesprochen hatten wir haben jemanden
der erfahrung hat das hat die union
soweit ich das einschätzen kann
zumindest auf bundesebene nicht nur
einen kandidaten zumindest in einen
potenziellen kandidaten und wir haben
eben ein zukunftsprogramm das wirklich
auch nach vorne schaut dass diese
möglichkeiten aufbietet und das eben
chance für die zukunft auch sein kann
und daher bin ich schon ziemlich
optimistisch dass wenn wir diese diesen
kurs beibehalten wenn wir auch dieses
zukunftsprogramm kommunizieren wenn wir
schaffen in den dialog darüber zu kommen
und unsere punkte zu setzen dass wir
auch gute möglichkeiten haben eben auch
olaf scholz als kanzlerkandidaten am
ende zu haben auch in einer regierung
die eben nicht der oder nicht die union
bei vanessa oder volksmusik glaubwürdige
politik machen das hängt auch viel von
der unterstützung seiner partei ab die
spd ist seit letzten sonntag wieder ganz
guter stimmung nicht wegen stuttgart
sondern weg mainz allerdings gab es in
der letzten woche oder letzten wochen
auch diskussion innerhalb der partei
wolfgang thierse der frühere
bundestagspräsident hat sich ja neulich
gefragt ob er noch in der richtigen
partei ist steht dann nicht auch
trotzdem eine auseinandersetzung
innerhalb ihrer partei über den
richtigen weg zwischen ich sage es mal
funktionärs apparat und den menschen die
man eigentlich als wählerinnen und
wähler gewinnen will
also ich muss ganz klar sagen dass ich
das eine kinder des kindergarten
diskussion fand die da irgendwie von
herrn thierse aufgemacht wurde
wir sind ganz klassisch eine volkspartei
die um den richtigen kurs ringt aus
verschiedenen perspektiven
jetzt ist es nun mal so dass die
parteilinken an der führung sind und nur
weil er sich da missverstanden fühlt
oder angegriffen fühlt mit dem austritt
zu drohen oder ihm anzubieten das fand
ich wirklich eine schwache leistung in
der zeit in der wir ganz andere probleme
haben
mit solch einer debatte einzufangen also
ich sehe dass die partei und auch gerade
die jusos oder teile der jesus kevin
kühnert hat es ja auch gesagt als juso
vorsitzender hinter olaf scholz stehen
die jungen menschen stehen hinter ihm
aber auch die älteren weil wir sehen das
natürlich ist gab diskussion auch um
diesen kandidaten und auch als
parteivorsitzenden ich meine ich glaube
dass alle mitbekommen wie im jahr
interessiert siege führungsduo und genau
genau aber die frage ist halt wie wir es
schaffen ab dem 26
eine progressive regierung zu bekommen
und da sich olaf scholz in dieser partei
definitiv als den fähigsten kandidaten
an
es ist ja noch knapp zehn minuten ich
würde sie ungern entkommen lassen aus
dem studio um sie nach den bündnisgrünen
noch zu fragen wenn man das jetzt am
wochenende gesehen hat vor allem
natürlich in baden württemberg auch da
viel euphorie in ihrer partei die partei
scheint ja auf der überholspur sich
zumindestens zu fühlen im moment was
kannst du noch falsch machen
ich glaube nicht so viel wie könnte
natürlich wenn sie übermütig wird ja und
jetzt so tut als hätten wir die wahlen
schon fast gewonnen und der erste grüne
kanzler oder kanzlerin wäre schon fast
im amt ich glaube dass sie das im moment
ziemlich klug sagen anlegen auf der
einen seite sich als eine partei zu
präsentieren die die zukunftsthemen
bearbeitet und tatsächlich auch
antworten hat auf die großen
zukunftsfragen wie den klimawandel wie
wir ökologische transformation der
industriegesellschaft schaffen
und gleichzeitig unseren wohlstand seien
erhalten können und so was wie maß und
mitte das ist ja eigentlich kretschmann
ja diese verbindung einer sehr großen
ernsthaftigkeit der politischen
weitsicht und pragmatismus und wenn sie
diesen dreiklang sagen schaffen dann
glaube ich haben sie tatsächlich
ziemlich gute chancen auf jeden fall in
der nächsten regierung vertreten zu sein
und vielleicht sogar in der lokomotive
er konnte in der vorbereitung zur
sendung habe ich gelesen dass sie
vermuten dass die bündnisgrünen vor der
bundestagswahl nicht die katze
beziehungsweise karte aus dem sack
lassen oder sondern eine tandem lösung
anstreben dass beide gemeinsam
spitzenkandidat ziehen damit er
eigentlich ein handlungsfähiger auch
kanzlerkandidat kandidatin der ist das
wirklich realistisch die grünen denken
gerne hybriden formaten als bewegungs
partei andere weiter an sich zu binden
nicht nur institutionellen formaten also
ganz neue konturen zu entwickeln und
dazu passt der charme dieses gedankens
als praktisch kanzlei tandem auch
anzutreten und die haupt wählerinnen und
wähler der grünen werden das tolerieren
weil sie wissen vertrauensvoll wird
dieses tandem am ende entscheiden welche
ämter aufzuteilen sind und dann
gemeinsam dazu auch eine lösung
präsentieren das hätte was etwas ganz
besonderes die kanzler als
kanzlerkandidat aufzutreten ist das
höchste ehrenamt nationalen partei
vergeben kann aber als war in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik das
erfolgloseste außer gerhard schröder hat
das ja keiner geschafft aus der
opposition dann kannst du auf einmal zu
werden darf ich dazu noch eine nachfrage
zu stellen wir euch den grünen ganz
kurze noch stellen wir sind gleich am
ende der sendung die zwei stimme bei
einer bundestagswahl ist die sogenannte
kanzler stimme glauben sie wirklich dass
die wählerinnen und wählern diese
zweitstimme vergeben wenn sie nicht
genau wissen das könnte ja passieren
dass die grünen entweder die größte
fraktion hat die größte fraktion
innerhalb des regierungsbündnisses wird
und dann wusste man gar nicht wenn man
damit mit der zweitstimme als
bundeskanzlerin oder bundeskanzler welt
das sehe ich so nicht sondern man möchte
dann damit auch eine gewinner formation
unterstützen wähler wollen fans des
erfolgs sein und die grünen dann sich
gut positionieren lassen die die grünen
unterstützen
es geht darum auch ein führungsmodell
offenbar zu unterstützen kooperative
führung gegenüber anderen modellen die
neo dirigistisch antreten um das mit den
kopfnoten noch einmal aufzunehmen das
sind ja die beiden verschiedenen modelle
diese sehnsucht dies eine durchaus in
krisen auch nach autorität und ansage
gibt und dann eben eher kooperatives
lavieren und ausprobieren das sind zwei
verschiedene stränge die man als wähler
idealtypisch bei unterschiedlichen
parteien mit unterschiedlichen personen
noch präsentiert bekommt darüber könnten
wir jetzt wahrscheinlich noch lange
reden das heben wir uns für die nächsten
sendungen auf ich bedanke mich bei
belegt laut zu hören war ralf fücks bei
andreas ritter und bei karl rudolf korte
liebe zuschauer morgen der phoenix runde
weil wir ein bisschen beim thema was wir
heute schon angesprochen haben es geht
um das astra zeneca debakel und die
frage wie gefährdet ist deutschlands ins
kampagne jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit
michael krons und auch da geht es um
dieses thema die europäische
arzneimittelagentur hat sich heute dazu
geäußert am donnerstag solle eine
entscheidung fallen das bleibt in sachen
impfstoff in jedem fall spannend und
deswegen bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]